um
[Music]
[Music]
to tell
[Music]
it's play school
i
did it yes
hello i'm emma hello i'm matt
well eddie is visiting us on play school
today he's just gone to go and get
something something fun for us to do
here i come oh here he is now hello
eddie hi matt hi emma hello eddie loves
maths
okay what are we going to do today eddie
we're gonna sort my odd socks
sort your odd socks okay
yeah i love sorting socks um do you like
sorting things too i must warn you
though these socks are really jumbled up
so
how are we going to sort all these socks
out uh well this sock is really long and
oh this sock is really short yeah and
there's different colors and stripes and
spots oh eddie this looks like a really
big problem big problems are just a lot
of little problems and if we solve all
the little problems we can solve the big
problem exactly why don't we start with
two piles one for long socks and one for
short okay um
well there's a long sock for you
and a short sock for me
short la de da
long lonnie d
short over here and long over there the
short and long socks everywhere
well done we've got one
two
two piles of socks
one pile of short socks and one pile of
long
but
these
socks this long sock has stripes and
this long sock has spots oh no and this
short sock has stripes and this short
sock has spots is there a way you can
sort your piles again into more piles
hmm
stripes over here and spots over there
stripes spots stripe spots everywhere
great job we've got one two
three
four
four piles of socks
one pile of short socks for sports
one pile of short socks with stripes
one pile of long socks with spots and
one pile of long socks with stripes
great work emery yes but
[Laughter]
this long stripy sock has green stripes
and this long stripy sock has black
stripes oh and this short spotty sock
has black spots and this short spotty
socks has white spots sounds like we
need to classify some piles using colors
classify as a fun way of saying sort out
classified
that's a great word eddie well come on
emma let's classify some socks
green over here and black over there
black spots white spots everywhere
[Applause]
amazing thank you so much all my socks
are sorted there's one
two
three
[Music]
four
five
six
seven
eight
eight pairs of socks wow that was fun
thank you so much everyone
well sorting socks is fun
and that's maths maths is fun maths
this is maths yeah it was but i thought
maths was just like numbers it's so much
more than that maths is a way of
thinking it's a way of organizing the
world and what we see and for organizing
our socks that's right you did such a
great job
i'm gonna go and find some more socks
more
okay
eddie loves socks
do you like sorting socks come on sort
with us
stripey spotty long or short
so many different socks too short
[Music]
where
do all these socks be long